hallo liebe zuschauer und herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer neuen episode
heute ist ein ganz besonderer tag
ihr habt lange drauf gewartet wir haben
lange darauf gewartet ihr habt oft
danach gefragt denn wir haben heute
einen ganz besonderen moderator der zum
ersten mal bei isar germany heute vor
der kamera stehen wird
es ist da
janosch hanisch ist mein mann und auch
der produzent und auch der kameramann
von easy german bei uns ist ja alles
miteinander verknüpft und johannes stuck
ist heute die episode moderieren
auf vielfache anfrage der schau genau
wir könnten uns der anfragen nicht
erwehren und deshalb jetzt bin ich da ob
ich es schaffe das werden wir sehen
jannis ich bin gespannt wie du das
machst aber natürlich die größte frage
die ihr euch jetzt aufstellt ist was
fragst du die rein ist ich frage ich
stelle den menschen eine einfache frage
eine sehr grundsätzliche frage auf was
ist der sinn deines lebens also der sinn
meines lebens ist ja eh germany
präsentieren meine ist auch okay dann
sind wir gespannt ihr fragt euch jetzt
wahrscheinlich im wer ist denn
eigentlich hinter der kamera jetzt wo ja
nicht weg ist da fahre ich einen kleinen
gegenstand vielleicht vorbereitet an der
kamera ist heute käme dass es kann will
unsere neue kamera für die heutige
episode wir sind gespannt
ich bin ja noch ich kann es kaum
abwarten haltet uns die daumen
hier ist ein mikrofon danke sehr und
walter scheel der genau wie ihr drehen
heute und zwar haben wir eine sehr sehr
klare und einfache und grundsätzliche
frage was ist der sinn deines lebens ist
eine ganz einfache frage natürlich in
ein wort ich mach zwei lebendig bleiben
was ist der sinn des lebens keine ahnung
was ich dich glücklich und zufrieden
sein
celcom pc lachen
der sinn des lebens ist die große liebe
zu finden
was ist der sinn des lebens liebe meine
freunde meine familie die sonne urlaub
und ganz viel spaß haben
glücklich zu sein menschen glücklich zu
machen
der sinn meines lebens
glücklich zu sein die zeit zu genießen
mit freunden familie gesund wasser
die liebe eine einfache frage der sinn
des lebens für mich ist andere menschen
glücklich zu machen
fehlende zwischenmenschliche beziehungen
arbeiten bei mir sind arbeiten völlig
unsinnige fragen würde ich doch mal
sagen so den wirklichen sinn des lebens
denn gibt es gar nicht innere
zufriedenheit halli hallo innere
zufriedenheit hier sein dasein
was ist der sinn des lebens der sinn
meines lebens ist verpflanzung und
menschen zu helfen sich war zu landen
danke sehr und wie machen sie das ist
dass ihr beruf oder war das jetzt ein
witz
was machen sie in der medizin sehr
einfache frage vielen dank
meine kinder vielleicht ganz bestimmt
sogar meine kinder wie was ist der sinn
idee sie auch gott ich finde ich als ich
hab philosophie studiert und da fragt
man sich doch ständig aber so eine
richtige antwort ist da einfach sehr
schwierig also eigentlich was alle mal
sagen glücklichsein am ende der systems
dass ich lebe ja die gibt's nicht was
ist der sinn des lebens
der sinn des lebens fürs deutsch zu
lernen und wunderbar deutsch zu sprechen
glücklich sein und zwar was ist der sinn
des lebens habe ich noch nicht gefunden
nicht nach dem sinn des lebens fragen
müssen was ist der sinn des lebens gibt
kein thema da was ist der sinn des
lebens etwas zu bewegen etwas zu
verändern dass man letztlich ist die
schöne nicht wirklichkeit sah ganz
andern er einen tieferen zufriedenheits
gefühl ein gutes leben zu führen kinder
groß zu ziehen
eine arbeit zu haben die einem freude
bereitet sich um die familie zu kümmern
auch die wände worden und auch die räte
ich habe überhaupt kein anzustreben
sagte manns und streben und überleben
also das habe ich irgendwo gelesen
ist das genug also immer wieder versuche
sagt gelte es ist eher so lange man
strebt solange man versucht ist es gut
das ist eine ganz tolle einfache frage
vielleicht den samstag sollen zu
verbringen
was ist der sinn des lebens sich zu
entfalten
und was ist der sinn des lichts
nach lebens überleben einstellen kann
echt weil es einfach überhaupt die frage
ist
also was ist heimat ausatmen was ist der
sinn des lebens
glücklichsein kleine momente genießen
der sinn des lebens leben freude am
leben zu genießen überleben was ist der
sinn des lebens
eine gute frage aber es kann auch keiner
beantworten
47 was ist der sinn ihres lebens
die thermische net 48 jahren so richtig
wir sind halt nur ein paar ich sag mal
ein paar augenblicke auf dieser welt um
zu leben denke ich mir mal weg und
vielleicht zu helfen genauso zu sehen
wie sich also genau wo sie von immer
noch nie obwohl ich und 48 jahre auf der
welt bin
kamel sind zurück aus der stadt
sie haben den ganzen nachmittag leute
befragt wie hast du denn jetzt
herausgefunden was der sinn des lebens
ist
nein eigentlich nicht es gab eine
aussage von einem menschen er sagte ich
suche antwort auf diese frage seit vier
und seit 48 jahren und habe sie immer
noch nicht gefunden
und ich glaube es sehr individuell es
hängt davon ab wie die menschen darauf
sind was die menschen für das wichtigste
an
es gab auch leute die uns gesagt haben
es ist
absurd die ganze frage ist absurd und es
gibt nicht so was wie den sinn des
lebens das gibt es nicht
glaube allerdings dass es gibt und es
gab auch menschen die diesen sinn des
lebens gesehen haben und das hat uns
sehr gefreut
absolutely absolut perfekte first shot
we make it possible to discuss the
picture
wenn dann wollen wir von euch jetzt
wissen was es dann für euch der sinn des
lebens vielleicht die beste frage wie
war ihr german auf der strasse gestellt
haben schreibt sind in die kommentare
schreibt uns mal wie die kamera von
kamel fand und wie er ja nicht als
moderator findet schließlich haben die
jetzt die nächste frage schon
schließlich habt ihr ihn ja frau die
kamera geholt
gebt ihm ein feedback und ich denke ja
nicht immer wieder in familien statt
nämlich selber auch ein großes feld für
philosophie und hatte auch ein bisschen
philosophie studiert das heißt
philosophische fragen sind genau sein
ding bitte und wenn ihr mehr sehen wollt
wie immer streitbar für uns und wir
möchten uns diese woche ganz besonders
bedanken bei denjenigen von euch die uns
bei chain unterstützen
danke dafür hier könnt ihr selbst
bleiben hier könnte
mitglied werden beim patchen und wenn
wir das seite kommt ihr zum beispiel
auch auf etwas ist zum beispiel die
woche hinter der kamera abgegangen viele
grüße aus pankow in berlin und bis bald